without a doubt hitman has been one of
the games of the year for us
now the first season has officially
ended we decided to take a look back and
pick our top ten favorite methods of
assassination and just before our
attempt to pawn after each murder you
have been warned the final training
level really lets us understand nothing
is out of bounds even at a heavily
populated area a stealth kill or rather
an accident could happen to anyone
our target is Jasper Knight a famous
chess master and Soviet spy who can be
persuaded to take part in a health and
safety check in a jet of all things it
is even possible to have him kill
himself by rigging the ejector seat
checkmate 47 very well played
I used to have a chess set by the way
but I pawned it next on the list
happened during Paris Fashion Week and
we were ordered to take down two
clothing gurus Viktor Novikov and Dalia
Margolis for forcing their designs onto
the world after triggering a fireworks
display it is possible to put one target
onto another this firework night
definitely went with a bang no I can do
better than that she really fell for him
off to Italy now are more precisely
Sapienza here 47 ticks out Silvia Caruso
who was created a bio weapon and
therefore cannot be trusted it turns out
that his love of golf is the way to take
him out by picking up an explosive golf
ball found at your apartment and placing
it in the golf basket moments before his
next lesson lets us witness this by the
way did you know why golfers wear two
pairs of trousers just in case they get
a hole-in-one you can also feed his
lifeless carcass into a grinder for
added effect I've heard about meeting
men through grinder but this is
ridiculous
next in our globe-trotting adventure is
Morocco here in Marrakech we take down a
despicable lawyer and a military leader
there are a few ingenious ways to
dispose of the terrible - including
dressing up as a prisoner and breaking
the Colonel's neck and even dressing up
as a masseuse and breaking the lawyers
neck these are both two very acceptable
ways to murder targets but our favorite
has to be luring the military leader
into a back room before dashing upstairs
and kicking a toilet onto his head
I was going to make a joke about toilet
paper now but they're just terrible
another opportunity asks you to be a
cameraman for an interview with glass
Stromberg while he sits and waits for
you to set up you can dash upstairs and
see how changing the light but
accidentally drop a moose on his head as
long as no one sees you you'll be
anonymous over to Japan for our top five
target assassinations starting off with
this beauty who is working for the big
bad guy miss disorders she has a love of
saunas especially fully clothed for some
reason ad by rigging the sauna to
overheat and by locking the door after
her you can witness her final few
moments she doesn't look very happy
maybe she should let off some steam I've
been told no one likes my solder puns
that really hurts my self-esteem
Eric's orders needs to meet his
comeuppance and luckily burrows he's in
hospital to receive a Dorner heart
agent 47 can lock his future heart and
expertly dispose of it in the nearest
refuse bin it turns out the way to a
man's heart isn't food who'd have
guessed it sorry that was a rubbish pun
sodas is being treated in a world
renowned hospital at the forefront of
Technology it has a computer AI
assisting with operations so of course
here lies the issue and agent 47 can
hack the computer to cause this fatality
I bet he feels exhausted after giving
that much blood I hear it's a draining
procedure the least elaborate way to
kill sadhus is by locating his operating
room and simply showing him your face a
face only a mother could love by the way
I looked over his nose and he originally
came in for a brain transplant but he
changed his mind finally our favorite
target assassination is performed on
Yuki yeah kisaki yeah kisaki becasue you
get you caucus you it's performed on
this young lady yeah the one that we
locked in this honor earlier it turns
out she loves yogurt just like agent 47
so the two meet up and take on such
pauses as the upward-facing dog
lot of the dance and the tree all
rounded off by the hit man push no puns
here I don't do yoga puns I will need to
be more flexible in future
I hear the yoga clinic is hiring now it
has many positions available together
anyway they were our 10 favorite target
assassinations in Hitman's first season
have we missed anything please let us
know below
I am Adam from Playstation grenade
please give us a like and subscribe for
more hitman content very soon and
probably more puns too